[Música]
puntos de oxígeno cientos de cambio de
ese estado
rayanos y rotos por la lista
no podrán compuestos comprarles
conscientes que existen los vientos de
cambio
estaba en ese tratado
[Música]
la próxima semana
nunca pensé que los vientos de cambio
donde se están haciendo muchas mensaje
y pensé que los que nos vemos muy poco
pocas veces pero cuando tengo la
oportunidad lo disfruto mucho la
disfruto mucho cómo disfruta mucho
gigantes y gran maestra
mucho
y vídeos
y menos tensión y los vientos de cambio
mejorada
de un momento a otro
a no casarme
[Música]
al tener que
correr pedir disculpas a mis
trabajadores no pagar más
y dividir
de la noche a la mañana
de deportes
[Música]
deportes
la carrera
pero nada práctico
el consume 20 demás y el último y en
esta ocasión
búsqueda sería perfectamente
[Música]
as
[Aplausos]
y así
sí y no
[Música]
faltando 10 minutos para detectarla el
partido nos vas a escuchar como
millos y absoluto de donde la tercera va
a perecer
entrevista con el conejo éxito total
fernández
salgo
[Música]
los músculos de las piernas de los
brazos y quiero hablar
sí
antes de los 7
i
y todos
[Aplausos]
lópez es este tipo de
a mis amigos
como si mi mamá y mis familiares temas y
quisiera trabajar caminando
y ah
y siempre y por siempre
al otro día no quería de verdad
estaba súper nervioso lo que entra
y yo
[Música]
en una dieta
hoy puedes hacer
después
de este evento los jóvenes salieron
[Música]
brillante
transmitido
en los medios no no no no entiendo por
qué existe una oportunidad es la línea
de stalin rivas y ma jin song
no puede ser que tengamos el mismo
talento y que analizar
algunas de las empresas dirigen éxito
total
porque américa la economía mundial pero
no
2015 el éxito son 120 metros cuadrados
[Música]
arriba
tuve que escribir a todos mis empleados
tuve que terminar una relación cuando
que va a pasar y si yo
y ya le conocían los montes serio hay
impuestos para el seguro social los
empleados
a
[Música]
pero si no es el mejor programa
en estos momentos
y muchísimos conmigo más
[Aplausos]
[Música]